well you'll hear a similar story for
many people my age I suspect I had a
very early interest in science and sort
of things physical and frankly a lot of
it came from the fact that at the end of
World War two there was suddenly on the
market all this amazing army surplus
equipment microphones and headphones and
radio components and very early on I got
interested in playing with things like
that with working with them with my
hands reading all the typical magazines
of popular mechanics and popular science
and so forth the interesting thing
however is that I never really developed
any affection at all for mathematics
until somewhat later and so it really
wasn't until about the time I was in
high school and college that I started
liking the more abstract analytical part
of science and engineering but a lot of
it really went back to playing with
surplus equipment I have to tell you
what other story because it's little
amusing one of my schoolmate and in
grade school one of my schoolmates
father was the commander of the local
State Police Post and one of the things
he had to do was raid places that we
were using slot machines and he'd have
to smash the front of the slot machine
and then his son and I got to tear it
apart and get all the relays and
components out of it so had a lot of fun
like that building model airplanes all
the usual things I studied mechanical
engineering as an undergraduate at West
Virginia University actually lived at
home and went to school to save money
and immediately upon graduation I was
married and we moved to Ann Arbor and I
started graduate school at the
University of Michigan and after that
for
or almost 20 years was a very
straightforward kind of academic
experience and career I did my thesis
work under a quite extraordinary
professor from Turkey named vadodara chi
and we worked in what I would really
call applied science today worked on
something called hydrodynamic stability
theory but it was a lot of work in fluid
mechanics thermodynamics heat transfer
which that time are very exciting fields
because they advanced quite dramatically
in association with the with a space
program but I worked in a more sort of
theoretical part of that then when I
graduated I ended up having several
opportunities to join good faculties
around the country but i ended up
staying at the University of Michigan
and when I did that I decided why should
do something really different the last
thing I want to do was stay on and
continue the kind of work my thesis
advisor it did so at that time the field
of holography three-dimensional
photography if you will based on the use
of then very new lasers was being
developed largely at Michigan because in
its modern form it was really invented
by two faculty members air am at Leith
and euro supid mix so I decided to go
over and start working in their
laboratory which was an entirely
different field populated by physicists
and electrical engineers and optics
experts I was the only mechanical
engineer I got very interested in how
this technique of forming these amazing
three-dimensional images of things could
be used to measure properties of
importance in the kind of engineering I
did so together with my graduate
students we developed a number of
techniques for taking these sort of
quanta qualitative images
making them quantitative measurement
tools and in particular became the enth
group where n is a very large number to
sort of independently discover the
principles of computer tomography which
most people know from the medical
applications getting three-dimensional
measurements such as you look inside the
brain structure and so forth we did this
for things like wind tunnels and flames
and chemical experiments and so I did a
lot of things all around the theme of
taking classical engineering problems
and applying this sort of radical new
measurement technique to it and moving
that technique from something that was
qualitative to something that can make
quantitative measurements that's sort of
in a nutshell is what I did I planned at
that point nothing other than a
straightforward academic career because
I love teaching that's really why I
became a professor even more than the
research side I love teaching working
with my graduate students doing research
and figured I'd probably do that till I
retired but things turned a corner later
you